all right now if you've ever desired a
JLo glow Pearl Skin studio the sponsors
of this segment they're back with the
deluxe Hydra facial that you need hello
Katya it's looking very chic
how you doing down there I'm jealous you
might get a hydra facial now
hydrafacials are great for men and women
especially in the desert what is a
hydrafacial so Hydro facial a lot of
people don't realize that it's actually
three-step process it includes cleansing
exfoliation and infusion of vitamins and
when I say exfoliation it means it
includes chemical peel which a lot of
people don't realize that it's a
chemical peel I did not know it has
three different strips of chemical peel
your estheticians should advise you what
chemical you should receive there is
very gentle one mild and very strong one
so it's up to me really to decide what
to do for the client depends on their
condition how their skin looks and
everything that's good to know I love a
hydrafacial didn't know there was a
chemical peeler now there's a new one
that you're demonstrating on our lovely
model and it is inspired by Jayla
yes tell us about that yeah the
treatment if you guys are looking for
that glow magic glow then while you talk
about it let's let's see it let's see it
in action so actually JLo boosted okay
magic gone
and I simply
Infuse the glow from JLo
and Christians you are getting JLo
infused to your forehead right now how
do you feel it has a lot of vitamins to
hold the hydration
and it treats Fine Lines wrinkles of
course great for pigmentation and of
course
smoothies the skin and hydrafacial
itself helps to extract the blackheads
without pushing on the skin without
bruising the skin right so the booster
by yellow is used towards the end of the
Hydra facial okay it's kind of like
cherry on top of the cake yeah well JLo
exactly after we do cleansing
extractions exfoliation this is infusing
her proprietary blend of vitamins
and it feels really really good as well
that's great so it feels good while it's
happening and then afterwards there's no
down time you're glowing you walk out
feeling good yes like JLo yes the best
thing after hydrafacial the results are
getting better day by days right right
in three five days you're gonna look
even better compared to the first day
when you got it I like that I like that
okay and you guys have the JLo Deluxe
hydrafacial at Pearl Skin studio so
thank you Katya and pearl Skin studio
for sponsoring this segment give them a
call at
702-525-5504 or visit
pearlskinstudio.com book a JLo booster
Deluxe hydrafacial appointment and you
can receive a free Jan Marini bio
glycolic cleanser that's 45 value When
you mention Las Vegas now we'll be right
back